The joe rogan experience.
Like I'm watching the show Vikings,
right?
And uh,
Oh man,
it pissed me off.
Episode two,
this guy puts his feet up on the table and he's got rubber bottom soles of his
shoe.
My Cue motherfuckers,
he has a healed,
it's clearly made in a factory and there's like this textured plastic bottom to
his shoe.
I'm like,
how did no one catch this?
You guys have is an amazing wardrobe and all these ships.
And I'll take a picture of it and I'll put it up on my Instagram later.
I was so dumb.
It made me angry.
But I'm watching this and I'm like,
how do we know who this was?
How they talked?
How do we know this is what they did?
How do we,
this is some weird interpretation of some historical events really to interpret.
And of course thoughts don't fossilize so I started off early in the book about,
you know,
who were the first people to figure out we're going to die and become aware of
our own mortality in a way that,
well,
maybe I can conceive of being somewhere else.
I don't actually die.
So we,
we know,
uh,
you know,
an elephant's grieve and mammals grieve and Cetaceans,
dolphins,
whales,
and so on.
And,
and,
and chimps,
they,
you know,
they feel these mothers are just,
just depressed and almost suicidal when they're infants die.
But that's different from,
you know,
conceiving of like,
well,
I know I'm going to die because I see people around me going to die that I
conceive of maybe some other place to go.
So I started off with something of a paradox that if I asked you to imagine
yourself dead,
you can't do it because to imagine anything,
you have to be alive.
So it's not going to be like falling asleep and waking up the next morning
because you have dreams or whatever.
It's going to be more like general anesthesia where it's,
you know,
10,
nine,
eight boom,
boom lights out and you,
and,
but you just never wake up.
So,
and we,
it's,
we talk about things like,
well there's nothing after death but,
but even the word no thing implies there's a thing or you know,
you're going to this place,
this [inaudible] there's,
there's nothing,
no thing or where it implies that there is aware that you're not going to,
but there's not even aware that you're not going to.
And it's like,
you know,
with Lawrence Krauss and some of these cosmologists,
what was there before the big bang.
So when you say,
well,
imagine no universe,
you know,
no stars or planets or galaxies,
no light.
But there's not even any space or time.
And at some point you just,
we don't have the words to even say what it is we're trying to talk about.
There's,
there's nothing before the big bang.
You can't even ask actually talk about it.
Well,
don't they think now though,
that it's important,
it's entirely possible that the big bang is like a cycle.
Yeah.
As well.
I think it's something like that I think expands and contracts infinitely
forever.
That that's a preferable,
well,
again,
we have to come up with some way to talk about it.
So we also have this weird biological idea based on our own limitations,
that there's a birth and a death of everything.
Right.
So actually I have a chapter devoted to Deepak Chopra and yeah.
Destroys,
don't tradition.
I work were kind of buddies now and yeah,
I went to his center down in Carlsbad and spent some time there.
And you think he's all right?
He's a good guy.
Yeah.
No,
he's totally a good guy.
He's been,
and at times in the past,
uh,
either misleading or misled.
Yeah,
sometimes that's right.
Um,
you know,
some of his recommendations for dietary things or whatever perhaps,
but I know for sure,
cause I've gotten to know him pretty well,
that he totally believes this stuff.
He says,
uh,
it sounds like we was,
I used to call it a,
but a lot of it,
if you interpret it from a kind of a Buddhist,
western Buddhist position,
you know,
when he says,
uh,
you know,
consciousness is the ground of all being,
it's the ontological primitive.
These things that sound nonsensical,
but if you think about it,
um,
sort of from a simple perspective,
the entire universe is in your brain.
And when you cease to exist,
the university says to exist,
or you,
but you are in your brain,
you know,
like,
I'll call it the week consciousness principle.
It's just sorta true by definition.
Now he goes a little bit further and says,
you know,
that consciousness is everything and that we bring into existence material stuff
by thinking about her observing and or whatever.
And here's some quantum physics experiments that are really spooky.
And it's like,
okay,
timeout.
You know,
quantum physics is weird and spooky.
Consciousness is weird and spooky.
That doesn't mean they're connected now.
He thinks they are.
So it's a debatable point.
Okay.
Uh,
but still,
um,
the,
the experience of going in and so we,
I did the meditation thing and all the massages and the teas and the food and
all that stuff,
and it's,
you know,
it's this beach side resort in Carlsbad.
You can't help but feeling better.
Like,
yeah,
this stuff works.
We're,
whereas Carlsbad,
it's down by Encinitas.
North of San Diego is a beautiful area.
Totally beautiful.
Yeah.
He's kind of deep box,
not done,
and he's got a good thing going and not just the buck,
you know,
there's other people like Sam Harris.
Bob Wright has a new book out called why Buddhism is true.
Okay,
so it works.
So we're back to,
does it work?
What do you mean by does it work?
Not just for me.
I had an experience and I felt better.
We got to do better than that for science.
So what Deepak and a brighter talking about is that is that the Western version
of Buddhism may actually work medically,
may lower stress hormones in your body,
but the lower blood pressure,
these kinds of things that are measurable because that's what we want to know
from a western scientific perspective.
Not just do I feel better,
but 67% of the people who did this particular treatment,
they got better by these measurable criteria.
Okay.
That's,
that seems fair enough to me.
I'm open to that.
Hmm.
Now this idea that there's nothing or no thing that we can't even,
we can't even wrap our head around nothing because we would think of a thing
that there's no thing,
but there's never a thing.
Right,
right.
But how do we or why,
why don't we just say we don't know.
Why don't we speculate on the possibility of consciousness being some sort of
ethereal thing or thing that exists outside of the Bible?
We don't know.
We really don't.
That's what I say.
I conclude.
I don't know if there's an afterlife or not.
The very end of the book,
we can come back to this later.
I just said,
it doesn't really matter whether there's an afterlife or not because we don't
live in the afterlife.
We live in this luck.
So this is the time you got to do whatever you got to do.
I called this Al V's error.
Uh,
Alvey is LV singer Woody Allen's character in Annie Hall.
I remember the scene early in the movie where he has a flashback as a young boy
and his,
he's in this psychiatrist's office with his mom.
And you know,
what's the problem?
He won't do his homework.
You won't do your homework.
Why won't you do your homework album?
He says,
the universe is expanding.
He says the universe is expanding,
goes to the universe,
is everything there is,
and if it's expanding one day it's all going to blow apart.
So nothing really matters.
I'm not going to do my homework.
And his father yells at him,
what does the universe got to do this?
We live in Brooklyn.
Brooklyn is not expanding.
So that's my sort of take home message.
We don't live in the afterlife or before the universe or after the,
none of that matters.
I mean,
it's interesting to talk about,
but we live in this life,
so this is what really counts.
They're fascinating things to contemplate,
but ultimately you really,
for practicality sake,
you really should be paying attention to life.
Totally.
I mean,
this is what I tell deep puck all the time when he says,
well,
you know Michael,
this table is actually made of atoms that are mostly empty space and the quantum
physicist,
Sean Carroll,
that's not correct.
Or was there,
right?
Yeah.
He explained that this idea of empty space,
he's like,
that's no,
that's just a poor way of describing.
Okay.
And R I would defer to him and let him describe it.
He also described the superpositions like particles,
subatomic particles being super position where they're in a state of moving and
not moving at the same time.
He explained that in a way that completely fucked my head up too.
I'm like,
well,
I thought I had figured out sort of,
I thought I had,
I didn't think I had to figure it out,
but I thought I had a definition that it least was like,
okay,
well it's this even though I don't understand.
And he's like,
no,
it's not even that.
Okay.
So yes,
referring to please,
if you're interested,
go to this Sean Carroll podcast.
Well,
as I understand it anyway,
that it doesn't really matter because the atoms are jiggling in a way that this
is solid.
You can tell it solid and this is the level we live at sell.
If somebody drops on your head,
you're in trouble.
That's right.
Yeah.
So again,
we don't live in a quantum world.
We live in a macro world where this kind of stuff does matter.
Okay.
So,
um,
you know,
to,
so for de Puck,
the whole Western way of thinking scientifically,
there's a beginning and an end time as a linear thing that we can measure and
there's birth and death,
all that is the wrong way to think about it.
That the Buddhist way is that it's just all consciousness.
And when you die,
he returned to the conscious state you were before you were in before you were
born.
So,
so the physical body is just an instantiation of this conscious thing,
whatever this is.
And okay.
I,
you know,
I don't know,
uh,
you know,
I'd be surprised,
but I'd be pleasantly surprised.
I'll tell you that if it turns out,
you know,
close my eyes for the last time and I wake up and,
there's deep pocket,
you know,
whoever my friends,
Carl Sagan and Stephen Jay Gould and all the greats,
Asimov are there.
Everybody's there hitches there.
You know,
it's like,
oh boy,
okay,
this isn't,
this isn't hell.
Uh,
if that's true,
you know,
I'm not against any of this.
Just like,
I'm not against Ray Kurzweil in these guys figuring out that we can live 200
years or 300 years.
Great.
If you can do it,
you know,
but let's just,
when they say to me,
Sherman,
don't you want to live to be 500 is like,
just get me to 80 without prostate cancer.
Give me the 90 without Alzheimer's,
you know,
a hundred uh,
gimme no hundred so I'm not on a morphine drip and a bed,
you know,
just quality of life incrementally year by year.
And if it turns out you solve these problems and we lived to 150 209 we have a
bunch of other problems we don't even know about yet.
Okay.
Well I think there's some beauty in temporary things that we,
for whatever reason we're,
we're avoiding that concept.
We were terrified of things ending.
There's beauty and things being temporary,
right?
You don't want to go to see a movie that's a hundred hours long.
It's running a movie's a great movement.
It's 90 minutes you're in,
you're out maybe two hours if it's three hours,
if it's blade runner or something,
something crazy like what Christopher Hitchens in my book is a love his analogy.
First of all,
you're at the party and death taps you on the shoulder and says you have to
leave.
And worse,
the party is going to go on without you and they're going to all have fun.
It's like,
oh no,
but if the Christian version of Heaven and Hell is real,
you're tapping on the shoulder at the party until you can never leave the party.
It's like,
oh,
that's even worse.
I don't want to,
I don't want to do anything forever.
Right?
And imagine the classical version of what heaven is like a guy with a harp and
there's a bunch of babies with wings.
Like what?
Or even that aside,
that there this y hitch called it a celestial North Korea.
You have a dictator that knows all of your thoughts and everything you're going
to do.
It's like,
wait a minute,
that that does not sound like fun to me.
Okay.